>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> David Plylar: Good
evening, everybody.
My name is David Plylar.
I'm in the music division
at the Library of Congress.
And I'm really pleased
- I don't know if any
of you were here last night
to hear the Dover Quartet
play [applause] - yeah.
Some fans already here.
It was a fantastic
performance last night.
And we get the rare
treat of getting
to hear the same music
performed again this evening.
Thanks. Yeah.
And so I'm very pleased to
have with me two members
of the Dover Quartet, Milena
Pajaro-Van de Stadt --
I knew I'd butcher it and so
I apologize - and Camden Shaw,
both on the lower
spectrum of the quartet
in terms of violoncello.
>> Milena Pajaro-Van de Stadt:
We're the grounded ones.
>> David Plylar: The
grounded ones, yeah [laugher].
And so we actually have a
lot that we can talk about.
The program that they're
doing is just fantastic,
and it's a very interesting one.
And maybe we could just
hit some of that material.
We'll go in order and
then talk about some
of your other projects
and things like that.
So maybe - I don't
know how many people
in the audience are familiar
with the music of
Viktor Ullmann.
Is it - a few, just a few.
But it's not a - not a kind of
a common - commonly-heard name.
So maybe you could say a bit
about how you came to learn
of this composer and to
pick this particular piece,
that kind of a thing.
>> Milena Pajaro-Van de
Stadt: Well, we hadn't -
we hadn't really heard about
him much, if at all, until -
was it three or four
years ago maybe,
a presenter out in
Santa Fe, Marc Neikrug,
who has us over at
his summer festival,
said to us that there
was this list of quartets
that were very dear to him
that people never performed.
And he sent them to us and said,
would you consider
playing one of them?
We started listening to them,
and we came across
Viktor Ullmann Quartet No.
3 and listened to it and
just loved it immediately.
So we -- we told him that's
the one we want to play.
So we started touring with it.
We learned about who he was.
He was a victim of Auschwitz.
And the piece he actually
wrote while he was interned
at Theresienstadt,
the propaganda camp.
And his - I think a dear
friend of his convinced him
to leave behind all his work
when he was being deported;
the day he was being
deported to Auschwitz.
And what remained of the
music were photographs
of what he had written on scraps
of whatever they
had in the camp.
And eventually people
took those photographs
and printed out the
actual parts.
And it's really a
fantastically powerful piece
and surprisingly
uplifting and triumphant.
>> David Plylar:
The - you mentioned
that Theresienstadt was kind
of a propaganda type of place.
I know that he was - he was able
to write quite a bit of music.
Actually, it was a surprising
amount, to me, of music.
But he was also active
as a critic
and other types of
things in this.
Do you feel that this - when
you approach - I should say,
when you approach the music,
does that come into play at all?
Or do you look at it
a bit more abstractly?
Or how do you deal with
that kind of baggage that -
that a work like that has?
>> Camden Shaw: That's a
- that's a great question.
I think with music this great,
as it really is, you could -
it works well in either context.
You can certainly see it in
that context of being in the war
and that he was at the
camp when he wrote it.
And that does give it a
certain extra power for sure.
But it's so great that
even not knowing that,
one would love the work.
And it is - as Milena said,
it's a really triumphant
and strong piece.
There was this curious thing
happening at Theresienstadt
where there was almost
the illusion of security
because it was the
only concentration camp
where the inmates didn't
have to shave their heads.
They could keep their hair.
There were a lot of artists
which were encouraged
at the time to produce some art.
And now there - there
are entire exhibitions
of only art from Theresienstadt.
So in a way it probably felt a
little bit safer than a place
like Auschwitz, but
it really wasn't.
And - and there was the day
where they shipped
everyone pretty much
from Theresienstadt
over to Auschwitz.
>> Milena Pajaro-Van de
Stadt: There's actually -
there's something about the
piece that - that makes me feel
in a certain way he was able
to escape his surroundings.
And for me, in a strange way
it's the moment where he -
he starts this fugue at the
end of the first part --
it's really in two big chunks -
when he starts this
fugue in the viola.
And it's - it's incredibly
beautiful.
We didn't realize for awhile,
but it's a twelve-tone subject
which is an interesting
connection to the Schoenberg
which is also in the program,
which is not twelve-tone.
But - but, you know -
>> David Plylar: She says,
don't run away [laughter].
>> Milena Pajaro-Van
de Stadt: But the -
the fact that he was able to -
to put his mind into something
like that, writing this
twelve-tone subject,
put harmonizing in
absolutely tonally
in the most beautiful way
that kind of masks the fact
that it was twelve-tone,
he was not only incredibly
emotional throughout the work
but also incredibly
intellectual.
And I feel like that was a
really - that was one way
for him to kind of turn off
what was going on around him.
>> Camden Shaw: Definitely.
And speaking more to - to
his lineage with composition,
he actually studied with
both Zemlinsky a little bit
and Schoenberg.
So there's a direct
connection with Ullmann
and those two - two men.
And it is really
amazing how [inaudible]
to combine different ideas
that were going on at the time.
So he was able to write kind
of with twelve-tone inspiration
but then, as she said,
harmonize it completely tonally
which was something that
was not done very often,
to sort of synthesize
these different ideas.
And the beginning of
the piece almost sounds
like Debussy or Ravel.
It's really focused
on atmosphere
and texture and color.
And there really - we
can't think of anyone else
that wrote really how he did.
It's also interesting
in the opening subject
of the last movement it uses
eleven out of the twelve tones.
So he's not attempting to -
it's not as if he was trying
to be twelve-tone
and came one short.
But his language was
just so close to that.
But he clearly was not
concerned with the rules
of twelve-tone writing which -
which could in a
way become a crutch
for some composers,
one could argue.
So it's interesting that he
was very open to these concepts
but was certainly not - not
imprisoned by them as ideas.
>> David Plylar: Yeah.
I would say, though, that
there's definitely a sense
of kind of - it seems
highly structured to me,
the way that he puts
things together.
And - and maybe there's more of
a kind of a harmonic affiliation
with Berg or someone like
that in bringing out some
of that romantic lineage
of that type of process.
I think the time
that he was studying
with Schoenberg was 1918 or
'19 or something like that.
So kind of an interesting time
for him to be in that orbit.
But yeah, you're right.
That makes it kind
of a very - I mean,
a poignant connection
to these people.
And with Zemlinsky,
his relationship here,
I think he was actually
his employee for a time
as a chorusmaster and repetiteur
and so -- at least I think for -
actually, for quite a
period of five years
or something like that.
But yeah. So speaking
of Schoenberg,
I should just mention for
those of you who don't know,
the Library of Congress
has the manuscripts,
the holograph manuscripts
of, I believe,
every work of Schoenberg
for string quartet.
And so this includes the -
at least the ones
that are existent.
We don't have some
of the movement fragments,
the earlier ones.
So I've just disqualified
everything I just said.
But we do have the 1897 one
which is - they're playing
and which is on display
tonight in the cases.
So be sure to check that out.
But, you know, it is kind
of - it's not one of -
it's one of his pieces
without an opus number.
What drew you to it and how did
you kind of come into the orbit
of this particular piece?
>> Milena Pajaro-Van de Stadt:
Well, for one thing we were -
we were already planning on
playing the Zemlinsky quartet,
and we really wanted to be
able to pair it with something
from Schoenberg because
of their close
and complicated relationship
with one another.
And then thinking about
a piece of Schoenberg's
that not only would provide a
lot of contrast to the Zemlinsky
but also just kind of a glimpse
into a part of Schoenberg
that people don't usually hear
was just very fascinating to us.
>> David Plylar: To me,
the - there's almost -
it almost leaps off the page.
This is - the piece
was written in 1897.
I think the American
Quartet was written in '94
or something like that so...
>> Milena Pajaro-Van de Stadt:
People usually think it's
Dvoracek when we play it.
>> David Plylar: Yeah.
It sounds - like, the first and
final movements, it just rings -
at the beginning, at
least, it rings of Dvoracek.
But yet there's - have
you played, as a quartet,
the other quartets
of Schoenberg?
>> Milena Pajaro-Van
de Stadt: Not yet.
I can't wait.
>> David Plylar: You know,
it's interesting though
because there's some things,
especially in the second
and third movements I think,
that start to come out;
that you see him picking up on
in the other quartets but...
>> Milena Pajaro-Van
de Stadt: Yeah.
>> David Plylar: Yeah.
The - is it - so surely
you've played a lot
of the Dvoracek quartets
and things like that.
Are there any distinctions
from this piece?
Or is it more like just
- should we think of it
as this is a piece that he
wrote when he was 23 years old,
kind of still in training?
Or is this a piece where -
>> Milena Pajaro-Van de Stadt:
Well, you hear - I mean,
you hear - you even
hear - for me it sounds
like there's a lot
of Brahms in that -
in this Schoenberg
quartet as well, just --
not even harmonically but also
there are certain figurations.
It almost -- it feels
like, that part in the end
of the last movement feels like
he's quoting Brahms almost.
And it - I think it's him
finding his own voice amidst all
the inspirations he had.
He didn't really have any actual
formal training as a composer
with the exception of his
mentorship from Zemlinsky
who was three years
older than him.
>> David Plylar: And which
in this case was particularly
important for this piece.
>> Milena Pajaro-Van
de Stadt: Yes.
Yeah, Zemlinsky gave him a lot
of pointers throughout the -
the scope of his
writing that piece
and I think also suggested
taking things out and kind
of basically helped him finalize
the piece, although he never -
it wasn't published
until after he died.
>> David Plylar: And the -
one of the interesting things
about this, we don't have the -
I don't believe - I'm not aware
of the original manuscript
being there for the version
that he had before he
went to see Zemlinsky,
which would be very
curious to see.
But this is the version that
- the version that we have
out here is the one he arrived
at after having worked
with Zemlinsky.
>> Camden Shaw: One
of the things
that we were noticing
just looking
at this manuscript a few
minutes ago was how meticulous
and beautifully written
it is just in terms
of the handwriting itself.
And there is this - "studious"
may not be the right word,
but there is a sense
that he's very,
very diligent about detail.
And that certainly wasn't
anything that left him later on.
But his focus was on
different details.
And certainly -- I
mean, Verklarte Nacht;
if I had to pick a piece
today that's my favorite piece
in the world, I would pick
Verklarte Nacht actually.
And - and it's hard to explain
a human brain being able
to produce something
like that so early.
And he - so he clearly was
exhibiting an immense amount
of talent and understanding
of beauty.
And this piece is really
interesting in that sense
that he really shows
a great understanding
of - of what's beautiful.
And there's some moments
in the last movement
that really take you by
surprise with their clarity
and - and transportiveness.
It's just - it's
an amazing work.
It really is.
>> David Plylar: It seems
like it's hinting
towards Verklarte Nacht
in some different
passages and -- definitely.
Yeah. And also the
orchestrational mastery
of Verklarte Nacht.
I mean, but to get there by
that time is pretty astounding,
when he was -- he would
have been 25 or so.
The - the second half of the
program features a composer
that we should hear more
of - we just don't -
Alexander von Zemlinsky
or just Zemlinsky.
And as Milena mentioned, he had
a mentorship role to Schoenberg
but also as a good friend.
And, of course, they had a
complicated relationship --
we can get into that but we
don't have to - in terms of how
that played out over the years.
But maybe looking
at the relationships
between this particular
quartet, the second quartet
which was written some 17
years after his first quartet
and the - not so much
the Schoenberg piece
but Schoenberg himself -
>> Milena Pajaro-Van
de Stadt: In general.
>> David Plylar:
-- what do you -
maybe you could speak
to that a little bit.
>> Milena Pajaro-Van
de Stadt: Well,
to me the Zemlinsky quartet
shows an extreme fondness
and admiration for Schoenberg,
the way that he writes it,
the way that - I
mean, first of all,
just even centering the
structure and the key all based
on Schoenberg's first quartet --
this isn't the one we're
playing; it's the one right
after that -- and the
very obvious references
to Verklarte Nacht which I think
he apparently told Schoenberg
at one point that he thought it
was beautiful even though it was
a little bit cheesy [laughter]
which is just shocking to me
because it's one of the most
transcendent works ever heard.
But then, you know, he obviously
loved it because he's - I mean,
this whole incredibly emotional
and just weighty, epic piece,
the Zemlinsky second
quartet, is just -
it feels like it's just
swirling - you hear --
you have Schoenberg swirling
around the entire time.
>> Camden Shaw: Yeah.
There's - there's
something really palpable
in the structure too
that the whole last page
of the Zemlinsky feels so
similar to the last page
of Verklarte Nacht and some
of the moments in the coda.
It's almost like when you've
known someone really well
and you just find out that
they have an identical twin;
and then you're looking
at the twin and it's
like everything's a
little bit different
but you're still
reminded of them.
it's - it's kind of
surreal, actually,
playing it in that sense.
The pacing is really
informed by - by that.
It's such a beautiful -
it's an amazing moment.
>> David Plylar:
And I might say --
this might be a little
bit irreverent to say,
but in some ways you could
say that this second quartet
of Zemlinsky is more radical
that Schoenberg's second quartet
which has the soprano solo.
And this is something that
he was very much - I mean,
it dates seven or eight
years before it, I think,
when he had the second quartet.
But the fact that this is -
while it is a multimovement-ish
kind of piece, it has this sort
of single, large span that he's
kind of going across in a way
that to me is pretty
darned convincing.
That's a - to me, it seems
like a major accomplishment.
But I would say just from
listening last night -
and I don't know if I mentioned
this to you - but the -
in many recordings I feel
that the complexities
of the work are focused on in
a way that takes away from some
of the - doesn't allow kind
of the inherent beauties
of it to come through.
And I think that you play it
very - with great clarity.
And so it's really a
pleasure to hear this live.
And I think that
you'll really enjoy it.
>> Camden Shaw: Thanks.
>> David Plylar: Do
we have anything else
to say about Zemlinsky?
Or should we - have you played
any of his other quartets?
>> Milena Pajaro-Van
de Stadt: No.
I listened to the - my fiance's
also in a string quartet,
and they are big champions
of Zemlinsky's, actually.
And they -- they do - they
perform the entire cycle
which is for string quartets.
But I - I've gotten to hear
them do that a few times.
>> David Plylar: Oh, cool.
>> Milena Pajaro-Van de
Stadt: And I like listening
to their recording of it.
>> David Plylar: Well, maybe you
could tell us a bit more about -
I know you have a lot of things
going on right now with lots
of touring and stuff,
but maybe some repertoire
that you have coming up or
we could also talk a bit
about your documentary
that you're working
on and things like that.
>> Camden Shaw: Yeah.
>> David Plylar: Anything
you'd like to talk
about I'd be curious to hear.
>> Camden Shaw: Yeah,
that's true.
No, I mean the documentary is -
is a really exciting
project we've been working
on now for more than a year.
And we've had - I could say
"crew" but no, they're, like,
really good friends that
have followed us around.
>> Milena Pajaro-Van de
Stadt: Well, the director,
he's actually based here
in D.C., and he is one
of my personal oldest
family friends.
But he - he's a fantastic
director.
He made a movie years ago that
I would encourage everyone
to go see called "Chops."
It's - it focuses on a young
- on a young group of kids
who are studying jazz
and kind of follows them
from middle school
through high school.
And they end up getting
accepted to the Jazz
at Lincoln Center competition.
And I don't want to say anything
more and give anything away.
But it's a really
great, inspiring film.
So when we were thinking about
how to get people who aren't
in our world or aren't really
a part of the chamber music
and classical music world
to see what we see in it
and to be excited by
it, we thought of -
his name's Bruce Broder
- we thought of Bruce
because he also isn't
really a part
of the classical music scene
and is fascinated by what we do.
So we felt like he
would have a good -
a good take on the whole thing.
Yeah.
>> David Plylar: When is it
set to be completed or...
>> Camden Shaw: It's not -
so far we don't know exactly
when it's going to be complete
in terms of a release date.
Most of the -
>> Milena Pajaro-Van de Stadt:
But the editing has
been - has started.
Yeah.
>> Camden Shaw: The
editing has begun, yeah.
So almost all of the footage,
at least, has been taken.
If they need something else that
they feel like - for instance,
one of the things
Bruce mentioned is -
that can happen often
in a documentary is you
catch everyone talking
about something, and then you
realize you never have any
footage of it.
So they may find that they
have to come film us, you know,
getting into a plane
or something
that obviously we
do all the time
but they may not
have footage of.
But it's at least, you
know, 98 percent complete,
the filming, which is great.
>> David Plylar: With the
structure of the film,
is it focusing on repertoire,
or is it following a
tour, or what kind of -
>> Milena Pajaro-Van de
Stadt: It's basically -
the idea of it is to get behind
the scenes of what it means
to be in a string quartet
specifically, full-time;
being a professional
musician, classical musician.
And they - they filmed
us doing everything
from making ourselves
breakfast in the morning
to performing a concert
in Salzburg, Austria.
And they just followed us
around everywhere we went,
took interviews of us,
people who knew us.
They even interviewed us
about very personal things;
relationship stories
and things like that.
So it's - it's really getting
- it gets pretty personal,
but I think the idea
is to really humanize
and make what we do David
Plylar: Not a mistake.
Yeah - no, it wasn't -
>> [ Inaudible question ]
>> David Plylar:
Well -- well, yeah.
But they -
>> I wanted to know who made
the decision [inaudible] -
>> David Plylar: It's a
mutual - yeah, a mutual one.
>> Milena Pajaro-Van
de Stadt: It's also -
one of the great things about
having done that or being
about to complete that is
the fact that we're playing
on these instruments
for the first time
and we're developing
miniature little -
little relationships with them.
So having played
an accessible and -
and show how connected it
is to the rest of the world.
>> Camden Shaw: And one
of the - the first reasons
that we decided this was
almost necessary to do this was
as we would travel
around the country and -
and Europe especially,
people were shocked
that we were classical
musicians.
Always. And we - we just
kept asking ourselves,
why are they shocked?
What is it about us that seems
surprising or incongruous
with their concept of what a
classical musician would look
like or act like or dress like.
Something wasn't what
most people imagined.
And so we started thinking,
how can we share the reality
of what it's like
so that maybe some
of these misconceptions
will be -
will be shattered
forever [laughter].
But we'll see.
It's been an exciting - exciting
and -- and as Milena said,
very personal process actually.
So it will be a little scary
for us to watch, I think.
>> David Plylar: Sure.
What other kinds of projects
do you have coming up?
Do you have any particular,
like,
programs that you're
centered on or composers
that you're thinking
about focusing on?
Or is it -
>> Camden Shaw: Well -
>> David Plylar: --
mercurial or changing?
>> Camden Shaw: -- it's
certainly changing and I think -
we just recorded our third
album this last summer
of the three Schumann quartets.
And that was a really wonderful
addition to our - our small
but growing discography.
They're wonderful pieces; very,
very romantic, very personal,
and really quirky and original.
And not played that often
because they're fiendishly
difficult
for how hard they sound.
They don't sound
nearly as treacherous
as they are [laughter].
And so they're - they're shied
away from too much, actually.
But they're - they're
wonderful pieces.
So we recorded those.
And then we have an exciting
- actually January coming up.
Maybe you can talk a
little bit about that.
>> Milena Pajaro-Van
de Stadt: Oh.
Oh, yeah. We have some fun
things coming up in January.
One of them is we have a very
short but packed tour in Europe.
It's just four concerts in four
days in two different cities
in Switzerland, Geneva,
Neoux, and then -
or is Neoux in France?
Oh, yeah. France,
Switzerland, then Germany.
And then we go to Amsterdam
and have our Concertgebouw
debut over there.
And then the very next day
we fly back from Amsterdam
to New York and have
our performance debut
in the big hall at
Carnegie as a part
of Janine Jansen's recital --
she's doing a six-recital
series there
with Jean-Yves Thibaudet,
the pianist.
And we're doing the Chausson
concerto with the two
of them in Stern Auditorium.
So that's very exciting.
>> David Plylar: Oh, very cool.
Well, I thought - we don't
want to keep you too long
so you can have a chance to
go get - back and get ready.
But would you be willing to
take a couple of questions for -
>> Milena Pajaro-Van de
Stadt: Yeah, of course.
>> David Plylar: Anybody -
audience, what I'll ask you -
we have -- Jay will come
by with a microphone.
This would be just so
everybody can hear your question
and we can record it so...
>> Hi. I always like to know
the personal things here.
And I - hello.
Okay. I noticed on
the announcement
that the music was not - was
not preannounced yesterday
or tonight.
And I wondered why you chose
to play the same
program again tonight.
I think it's an interesting
decision.
So that's one question.
And the other is I'm
always interested
to know how musicians
come together
to form whatever
group they play in.
Thank you.
>> Milena Pajaro-Van de Stadt:
I thought that it was
always the same program.
>> David Plylar: No - yeah.
It was - it's - it's unusual.
We used to do -- back when
the Julliard Quartet was
in residence they used to
do multiple performances
of the same works
over several days.
It just happened to
work out this time.
We don't usually do that.
It happened to work
out to do it,
and I think it's a fantastic
opportunity when it's possible
because then you not only -
>> So it was an [inaudible]
decision and not a decision -
>> actual performance on them
was a huge learning experience.
And then to get to do
it again once you've had
that experience will
be very rewarding
[ Inaudible question ]
>> Milena Pajaro-Van de Stadt:
We'll do our best [laughter].
Oh, and then how we got
together as a quartet?
Was that your other question?
>> Yeah.
>> Milena Pajaro-Van
de Stadt: Well,
we were all in undergrad
together
at the Curtis Institute
in Philadelphia.
And Camden and I,
actually our freshman year,
started playing together
in a group
and instantly bonded musically
and really loved
playing with one another.
And in the meantime, the two
violinists, Joel and Bryan,
who had been at the
school a year earlier
than us were already
in a quartet together,
a quartet that we
both really admired.
And so we really loved their
playing, especially as a pair.
And eventually - I think it was
our third year at Curtis - yeah,
three years in, their quartet
was kind of a little bit less -
they were a little less
serious in some ways
than they had been before.
Their older - their other two
members were a little older.
They were about to graduate.
Actually, one of them
is my now-fiance.
He used to be in a
quartet with them.
But they - so it looked like
their quartet wasn't going to,
you know, continue
as a permanent group.
And so we eventually
approached the pair of them.
And our topless quartet
and their bottomless
quartet formed a brand-new
quartet [laughter].
>> Camden Shaw: Formed a
completely naked quartet.
[ Laughter ]
>> Camden Shaw: That's why
we're doing the same program.
Tonight will be the naked one.
[ Laughter ]
>> David Plylar: I
should mention I --
I completely neglected
to say this is our
Stradavari anniversary concert.
We usually do it on
December 18th, and that's -
so we had that yesterday.
But it features the instruments
that were given to us
by Gertrude Clarke Whittall.
And you can read
more about that.
There will be an insert in your
program just to read a bit more
about each of the
instruments there.
Jay will pass - go ahead.
>> Yeah. I had a
question actually relating
to those instruments.
How does it feel to play those
instruments, especially compared
to the instruments that - you
know, I don't know what kind
of instruments you usually
have the privilege of playing.
But what is it - what
is it like to be...
>> Camden Shaw: It's -
it's a lot of things.
That's a great question.
They're - I mean, the Strads
that we're playing tonight
are incredible instruments.
They're - they're
very different.
And as you can imagine, so
much time has been spent trying
to be accurate in terms of
dividing these enormous strings
into really a, you know,
hundredth of a millimeter.
So what's really hard is trying
to do that well on an instrument
where all the dimensions
are different.
And that's something that
we're all - you know,
adjusting to a new instrument
is very difficult in that sense
because your instincts of
where things are, are wrong.
So you have to sort
of open up your mind
to where B natural might be and
- and I actually think, though,
it - I was noticing that it
changes the way, I think, your -
your brain conceives of the
fingerboard when you're thrown
into a new instrument
kind of situation.
Because instead of
thinking in absolutes
of where you know things are,
you're a little bit
more exploratory and --
and if - you know, you actually
end up having to be looser
because if you commit to a
position that you're sure of,
you're probably going
to be wrong.
So there's just a sense
of a lot more fluidity
which is really a great feeling.
The cello is - just from
my perspective playing
that is enormous.
It's very large, and
so it's - it has a lot
of different challenges that
I'm not used to with mine.
Some of my fingerings
I had to change
because I actually
couldn't reach them anymore
and things like that.
But it also has the best
C string I've ever heard
on a cello so - so it's really
fun, and I don't really care
about the challenges [laughter].
It's great.
>> Milena Pajaro-Van
de Stadt: With the -
with the other instruments,
the violins and the viola,
one big difference
for me - and this --
this is for when you play any
instrument you've never played
before - is how close the
instrument is to your ear
and the sound that is coming
out is so distinctly different
from what you're used to.
I've played on my viola
for almost a decade now
and basically never
on another one.
So playing on a different viola,
it just sounds so foreign to me.
And it's hard to gauge
how it's interacting
with the other instruments in
the group, not mention all four
of us are playing
different instruments.
So then it - like, it's
like a completely new
chemical reaction.
It's not just changing
one ingredient.
It's all the four new
ingredients and figuring
out how they're responding to
one another, how the balance is,
what's actually going
out to the audience.
It's very challenging
and - I mean, it's -
it's a great learning
experience, like I said before.
>> Camden Shaw: It is.
I mean, I think we - we don't
even realize just how much
of our group sound is defined
by the instruments that we play.
And so to have that completely
changed where all four of us are
on different instruments throws
new assumptions into the mix
of what's going to - you know,
what it's going to sound like.
And actually, our - our manager
who was there last night --
it was really cool, and he
didn't mean this in a bad way
at all - but he's heard us
play, you know, so many times
and all different
venues all the time.
And so he really knows
what we sound like.
And so we asked him, like,
what -- you know, what did -
what did we sound like?
He was, like, it
was - it was cool
but it was weird [laughter].
Because he's so used to
it being like - you know,
he knows the way that we talk,
but suddenly our voices
are completely different.
>> Milena Pajaro-Van de Stadt:
All our voices are different.
>> Camden Shaw: So it was -
it was really interesting.
>> Milena Pajaro-Van
de Stadt: Yeah.
>> Camden Shaw: It as fun.
>> I had a question
about the Ullmann.
And first I have to say that
yesterday was phenomenal,
and the opportunity to
hear the program again is
just incredible.
So thanks to you and to
the Library and whoever -
all the people who
made it possible.
This is a real treat.
>> Milena Pajaro-Van
de Stadt: Thank you.
Yeah.
>> But I have to ask about your
description of Ullmann as --
the Ullmann piece as triumphal.
And I know that when you learn
to play a piece you have
a different relationship
that certainly on
a first hearing.
And to me, it just
left me tingling
and especially with the contrast
of the Schoenberg which was,
like, such a different,
light color.
The Ullmann seemed to
me kind of apocalyptic
and sort of a primal scream.
And I don't know if that - you
know, how - and particularly
with the CD pieces that you
have which are all kind of -
of a certain emotional feel,
I'd like to understand
the triumphal part.
I want to help -- listen to
this [inaudible] tonight.
>> Camden Shaw: That's a great
- well, that's a great comment.
And the - the first
thing that came
to my mind is all different
interpretations emotionally
and -- and intellectually
looking at the manuscript
of anything are -- are valid.
So, you know, just because
we would feel one way if -
and it has a different reaction
from someone else
is completely valid.
I think - I really like your
description of it, though,
and I completely agree actually.
I think when we're thinking
of it as triumphant,
one of the things I
know we talked about was
that you can tell
he was not afraid.
So there's a - there's a
real strength there that's -
that's quite surprising
and very strong.
And so yeah, it's not a
happy triumph necessarily,
but it's really potent.
And it's almost like this
raging fire that's just not -
>> Milena Pajaro-Van de
Stadt: You don't feel defeated
at the end of the piece even
though it is heartbreaking.
You don't - you feel empowered.
>> Camden Shaw: Yeah.
>> Milena Pajaro-Van
de Stadt: Yeah.
>> Camden Shaw: Yeah.
But that's - I like
- I completely agree
with your - your response to it.
Absolutely, yeah.
>> Milena Pajaro-Van de Stadt:
Oh, I should mention the CD.
Should I say something about it?
>> David Plylar: Yeah, sure.
Sure.
>> Milena Pajaro-Van
de Stadt: Yeah.
She - she mentioned the CD.
The Ullmann that we're playing
tonight is the first piece
on our newest album
that we released
which is called Voices
of Defiance.
And it features music written in
1943, the Viktor Ullmann; 1944,
Shostakovich's Second Quartet;
and 1945, the Third Quartet
by Simon Laks who survived
over two years in Auschwitz
by being - basically by
being made the director
of the Auschwitz orchestra.
So that - and that - this
piece that's on the album
of his was the first
thing he published
after they liberated the camps.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Milena Pajaro-Van
de Stadt: Simon Laks.
>> David Plylar: I
think we have time
for maybe two more
quick questions.
>> I have another
question and - oh.
I have another question
[laughter]
and I think it might be quick.
I don't know.
But I came in and I noticed
where the instruments
used to be.
But you're not using any
of the Library's bows.
Is this a "bring your own bow"
>> Milena Pajaro-Van
de Stadt: BYOB.
>> Camden Shaw: BYOB.
[ Laughter ]
>> Milena Pajaro-Van
de Stadt: It sure is.
>> And Happy Hanukkah.
>> David Plylar: We - some of
the ones that we have are not
in - they're just not in
a condition to be played.
We do have some Tourte bows
that are very unique and viable
and what not but they're just
not - it wouldn't be safe
for them or for the
instruments for us to use them.
So they're more just a
visual thing at this point.
So we always have our
artists bring in bows.
I think we have one - one
more up here and then - yeah.
One second.
He'll give you a...
>> While she was talking
[inaudible] the third
question first.
You wondered how
you would sound.
Did you hear before
you did the concert?
Did you hear a recording so that
you knew what you sounded like?
>> Milena Pajaro-Van de Stadt:
We didn't listen to a recording,
but we did take turns
going out into the hall
and then commenting and
reacting back to one another
to what we were hearing
from farther away.
>> And -- well, the first
question was do you -
assuming you know in a way that
the range from young to very old
to - he never got very old -
to older and more developed,
do you consider the Ullmann
and Schoenberg essentially
young music but with residues -
with traces of early stuff?
Do you think of it as
young music in relation
to what they evolved
into being as musicians?
>> Camden Shaw: That's
a great question.
I think with Ullmann we don't
know how he would have developed
later -
>> Precisely.
>> Camden Shaw: -- and
so it's hard not to feel
that it's somewhat
final in that sense.
>> [Inaudible] triumphal
and sad and primal.
So look at the situation
he was in.
>> Camden Shaw: Yeah.
>> David Plylar: He
was about 45, I think,
when he wrote that piece.
>> Camden Shaw: Yeah.
Yeah.
>> David Plylar: So he
had a - he had a career
that had predated --
that - where he had produced
quite a bit of music,
unfortunately, a lot
of it lost but...
>> Camden Shaw: It does -
that pieces, the Ullmann,
does also strike me as
a little bit more sure
of what he wanted to sound like.
The - but that could be
just because, you know,
we know how much
Schoenberg would change.
It's hard to know.
You know, if he hadn't changed,
we might see it as more mature.
But - but this Schoenberg
does strike me a little bit
as the amazing paintings
of Picasso before he -
he turned to different styles.
And so obviously it's so
much talent, but maybe not -
he hadn't come into
his own vantage yet.
>> But Ullmann developed on
something he had done earlier?
You could hear that?
>> Camden Shaw: Well, I'm sure
Ullmann's work developed a lot
but - but -
>> David Plylar: So there's
- there's about twenty
or so pieces that
are still out there.
There's a - the greatest
continuity is in the leader.
There's about sixty
songs that still exist.
And you can definitely trace
his - his style in there.
But he also - he was - by the
time that we have things that -
that -- the things that
did survive, there's a -
I think that there's a -
you get the sense of him
as a composer all throughout it.
Unfortunately, with the string
quartets I think the only other
one that - there's
an arrangement
of his Schoenberg variations.
So there's not -
there's not much
to compare it to unfortunately.
So it's hard to know whether
- you know, whether it was -
would have been a departure.
But it certainly is in
line with lots of his -
with other instrumental
music, I think.
>> And the last -
you're too young
to have seen maybe [inaudible].
Did you see the fabulous
documentary
of the Guarneri Quartet?
>> Milena Pajaro-Van
de Stadt: Oh, yes.
Absolutely.
>> The Voltaric - I
mean, the friction?
[Inaudible.] I mean, it
was - it was a [inaudible].
>> Camden Shaw: Well, you
think that was intense,
just wait till our documentary.
[ Laughter ]
>> So you're open about your -
>> Camden Shaw: Well,
I think - yeah.
>> Milena Pajaro-Van de
Stadt: Oh, excuse me.
I think there are a
lot of candid moments.
We're not - and we talk
about all the difficulties
and the group dynamics and how
alliances are always seeming
to shift and ebb and
flow and it's - yeah.
It's a tough and exciting
and rewarding life.
>> David Plylar: On that
note, I think we do need to -
to go ahead and stop here.
But I'd like to thank Milena and
Camden so much for joining us.
They have to go get ready to
give us a show tonight so -
>> Milena Pajaro-Van
de Stadt: Thank you.
>> Camden Shaw: Thanks
so much for coming.
>> David Plylar:
-- thanks so much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.